in this lesson we're going to talk about
percent of change so how do you
calculate percent of change what's the
formula and how do we work with it in
terms of doing story problems and act
type problems well
the formula you want to know here is the
percent of change is equal to the new
amount minus the old amount divided by
the old amount so basically when we do
new minus old that's giving us you know
what is it changing by how much is the
difference what is it how much has it
changed by but you want to compare it to
what it was originally okay the old
amount
so sometimes students get this little
bit messed up you know they'll divide by
the original amount i'm sorry not the
original amount but the new amount and
you really want to divide about by the
original amount or the old amount
because you're trying to see how it's
changing compared to what it was so
let's go through an example and see how
we work with this so see if you can do
this on your own and we'll go through it
together if a sweater normally sells for
forty dollars
but online it sells for twenty eight
dollars what is the percent change from
the store to the online price right and
we've got some options a b c d
okay so what we would do here is we take
the new price which is 28
minus the old price which is 40 divided
by the
old price which is 40 right so 28 minus
40 is
negative 12
divided by 40. so let's see we'll go to
the calculator here we've got a negative
12 divided by 40 which is
negative 0.3 now you're probably
wondering
what is the negative 4 well the negative
just means that it's going down in price
it's decreasing if it was positive it
means it would be going up in price
this is a decimal to convert it to a
percentage you just move that decimal
two places to the right so this is
actually going to be a 30 change and the
best answer here is going to be letter c
so again new minus old divided by old
that's how you calculate percent of
change